like if you took out the trash sometime  you're the boss for you and see that the  trash is getting over filling you just  grab it and take it out maybe in your  mind you think you'd be losing respect  but you actually wouldn't be at all in  fact everyone looks into those oh he's a  good guy  and you're working for me and you still  gotta maintain the discipline the more  that you treat them with respect or  didn't respect you they're gonna know  that you're not too high they're gonna  know that you're down to earth when I  was a teen commander Tashkent commander  I picked up brass I cleaned the ranges  with the boys I would recommend that  kind of absurd it didn't make people  think Oh Jacques  does not even better to do that actually  knew I had stuff to do but what I'm  gonna do they've got brass with the boys  ability relationships set the example  they'll respect you for it  [Music]